Hillary Clinton trashes Bernie Sanders
just two weeks before the Iowa caucuses
the Senate impeachment trial rules are
set and the media tried to spin a
pro-gun rally into a white nationalist
terror gathering I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show this show is
sponsored by expressvpn stop putting
your online data at risk you get
protected at expressvpn dot-com slash
Ben well today is the beginning of the
Senate impeachment trial it is expected
to last for perhaps a week and a half
maybe two weeks at most we will get into
the Senate impeachment trial stuff in
just a second because the media are
fighting mad at Mitch McConnell Mitch
McConnell of course is expediting the
process after the Democrats has
submitted a wholly insufficient
impeachment memorandum suggesting why
they had impeached without actually
mentioning a crime but here's the thing
all that's really boring okay we know
that the impeachment stuff is really
just a setup for 2020s election coming
up in a few months we know that this is
going nowhere in the Senate we know
there are no real bombshells that are
going to drop between now and then and
that the entire impeachment effort was
basically a two-fold charade one Nancy
Pelosi attempting to get the crazed
loons on the far left off of her back
and two trying to smear Trump just
before the election and so really this
is about the 2020 election and when it
comes to the 2020 election something
exciting just happened Hillary Clinton
is back baby and she is better than ever
oh yeah so Hillary Clinton has been
sitting off to the side ever since she
lost the 2016 election and she's been
kind of taking potshots & sniping at
Trump and she'll go on Twitter and
she'll fire off some passive-aggressive
tweet and then we'll see a weird picture
of her standing behind some sort of mock
Oval Office resolute desk abroad and
we're all like okay what's Hillary doing
these days and it turns out she's doing
nothing
well now it turns out she was doing
something she was filming some sort of
docu-series she was filming a
documentary series as you would suspect
is all about how Hillary Clinton is the
bestest person in the entire world as a
four part Hulu series titled Hillary
sets a premiere at Sundance and Hillary
Clinton opens up and not only does she
open up on President Trump which you
would expect and on the Monica Lewinsky
handling all the rest she opens up her
guns on Bernie Sanders and I mean goes
directly at Bernie Sanders
she hates Bernie Sanders and I am here
for it man break out the popcorn let
them fight ah
oh it's fantastic pick your fighter
Bernie
versus Hillary I'm here for the Silent
Generation Democrats all of whom are
walking around at this point with
walkers with tennis balls on the feet
I'm all about them just beating just
clocking the living crap out of each
other I am here for it I am up for it
and in just one second I'm gonna tell
you what Hillary Clinton said about
Bernie Sanders because it's great for
Bernie
it really is is great for Bernie there
is one surefire surefire rule in
American politics over the last 12 years
or so and that is if you run against
Hillary Clinton that's awesome
Barack Obama found that out in 2008 and
then Bernie Sanders founded out again in
2016 and then Donald Trump found it out
in 2016 if you want to be popular all
you have to do is run directly against
Hillary Clinton and as we are about to
see Hillary Clinton took off the gloves
and just went right at Bernie Sanders
she smacked away his pudding and he is
going to have to respond I mean he
doesn't really have much of a choice
we'll get to that in just one second cuz
it's pretty glorious first let us talk
about your safety and security so as you
can imagine I am nearly paranoid about
my safety and security and that of my
family
we have full-time security that's
because I have so many death threats
unfortunately a lot of people want to
hurt us but our city is also turning
into a giant slag heap I mean this is
just a terrible terrible city crime
rates are going up petty crime we've had
break-ins in our neighborhood and that
is why I rely on ring and so does my
wife my wife is similarly concerned
about safety obviously we have two young
kids and a third on the way and that is
why we do rely on ring rings mission is
to make neighborhoods safer there's
smart video tour bells and cameras
protect millions of people everywhere
this is particularly important in LA
where again crime rates have been going
up because the local government has
refused to crack down on any sort of
street crime at all ring helps you stay
connected to your home anywhere in the
world so if there's a package delivery
or a surprise visitor you do get an
alert and you're able to see here and
speak to them all from your phone go
check out ring right now as a subscriber
you do have a special offer on a ring
welcome kit available right now at
ring.com
slash been the kid includes a video
doorbell and the chime Pro which is what
you need to start building that ring of
security around your home today go-to
ring
/ Ben that is ring.com / Ben are ing
calm / Ben ring.com
/ Ben alrighty so Hillary Clinton does
this docu-series with Hulu and then she
did an interview with The Hollywood
Reporter and this thing is just brutal
it is just brutal so the documentary
apparently doesn't feature Monica
Lewinsky nor Bernie Sanders nor Donald
Trump the director says I didn't want to
relitigate 2016 which listen that's the
only reason that you're making a
documentary about Hillary Clinton who
has not been relevant for four years at
this point but the director explained
that that she didn't want to relitigate
2016 as much as just be able to show
Hillary in this unobtrusive way but a
bunch of other people did talk to the
documentarians including Bill Clinton
who holds back tears as he walks through
the Lewinsky chapter well it's good to
know that Bill Clinton can still turn on
the crocodile tears even at age 97 but
there's really only one question for
Bill Clinton that is worthy of answering
and it's whether that prostate is still
in action who lose head of documentaries
that beliefs of ala bon says this is not
an agenda piece it's an offered piece of
work that looks at a very long slice of
personal and political history no it
doesn't sound like propaganda at all it
sounds like it is perfectly balanced in
its approach to Hillary Clinton but this
is not a rip on Hollywood the important
part is that Hillary is now just taking
out a machete and she is hobbling around
the house yelling at Bernie Sanders
well he says well my slippers I don't
dunk the struggle my slippers are just
like I'm coming after you at the machete
I don't know what my flippers are I
couldn't run outside the way from
Hillary Clinton unless I find my
slippers so here is what she said to The
Hollywood Reporter quote so this is the
interviewer in the documentary you're
brutally honest on Sanders this is
direct quote from the documentary he was
in Congress for years he had one senator
support him nobody likes him nobody
wants to work with him he got nothing
done he was a career politician it's all
just baloney and I feel so bad that
people got sucked into it okay I mean
this by the way this Hillary Clinton
would have won walking away in the
primaries and she did end up winning the
primaries more votes than Bernie but it
was very narrow this Hillary Clinton who
basically just dismissed Bernie as a
know-nothing communist would have done
much better in the primaries than she
actually did instead she sort of tut-tut
did Bernie all the way to the finish
line and as we have learned in the game
of American politics
is actually not a smart strategy people
did this with Donald Trump in 2016 they
sort of patted him on the back all the
way until he won the nomination and
Hillary Clinton basically patted Bernie
Sanders on the head all the way until he
almost stole her thunder but here are
her real feelings which that Bernie's a
useless commie which is correct Bernie
is a useless commie if Hillary Clinton
had said this about Bernie Sanders
during the primaries I've been there
applauding because this is exactly right
he was in Congress for years he doesn't
have his name on one significant piece
of legislation
he sat outside the Democratic Party and
did nothing for 40 years
while taking tax payer dollars and then
proclaiming himself pure of heart well
literally accomplishing zero things and
being wrong about all of them so they
asked her does that assessment still
hold and she says yes it does and here
this is the best part The Hollywood
Reporter says if he gets the nomination
will you endorse and campaign for him
now remember the rip on Bernie had been
that if Bernie did not get the
nomination then he and his Bernie bros
would walk but here is Hillary Clinton
basically ripping the scab off right if
he gets the nomination will you endorse
and campaign for him quote I'm not going
to go there yet we're still in a very
vigorous primary season I will say
however that it's not only him it's the
culture around him it's his leadership
team so she's not just going after
Bernie she's going after everybody
around Bernie his leadership team she's
going after the Bernie bros she's going
after her his entire constituency base
hey and if Joe Biden who is the
hand-picked Hillary Clinton successor is
the person who wins the nomination you
think maybe some of the Bernie bros are
going to remember that Hillary Clinton
and Team Obama stood aside while Hillary
Clinton just savaged Bernie Sanders and
his entire band of married commie
supporters I'm not gonna go there yet
we're still in a very vigorous primary
season I will say however it's not only
him it's the culture around him it's his
leadership team it's his prominent
supporters it's his an online Bernie
Bros and their relentless attacks on
lots of his competitors particularly the
women and I really hope people are
paying attention to that because it
should be worrisome that he has
permitted this culture not only
permitted he seems really to be very
much supporting it and I don't think we
want to go down that road again
what are you campaign by insult and
attack and maybe you try to get some
distance from it but you either don't
know what your campaign and supporters
are doing or you're just giving them a
wink and you want them to go after comma
law or after Elizabeth I think that's a
pattern that people should take into
account when they make their decisions
so here she is saying we shouldn't wink
and nod and attack
we should really lay off the attacks
also Bernie's an ass Bernie's a jackass
he's a sexist jackass and the people who
support him are sexist jackasses oh this
is so good
more more directly into my veins yes so
the interviewer then says speaking of
Bernie allegedly told senator Elizabeth
Warren in 2018
he didn't think a woman could win a
statement Eva grossly denies how do you
digest that Hillary Clinton quote well
number one I think that sentiment is
untrue which we should all say loudly I
mean I did get more votes in both in the
primary by about four million and in the
general election by about three million
I think the both the press and the
public have to really hold everybody
running accountable for what they say
and what their campaign says and does
that's particularly true with what's
going on right now with the Bernie
campaign having gone after Elizabeth
with a very personal attack on her then
this argument about whether or not or
when he did or didn't say that a woman
couldn't be elected it's part of a
pattern if it were a one-off you might
say okay fine but he said I was
unqualified I had a lot more experience
than he did and I got a lot more done
than he had but that was his attack on
me okay first of all that part not so
true right Bernie Sanders has been in
the Senate since before Methuselah was
born Hillary Clinton was elected to the
Senate in 2000 she served like a term
and a half and then she ran for
president of the United States it was
only after that that she ran for said
that she became Secretary of State and
then ran again he says she says I just
think people need to pay attention
because we want hopefully to elect a
president who's going to try to bring us
together and not either turn a blind eye
or actually reward the kind of insulting
attacking and demeaning degrading
behavior we've seen from this current
administration
so in this interview she has called it a
sexist she has suggested that his entire
campaign has been built around viciously
attacking other people and she has
suggested she won't even commit to
endorsing him if he wins the nomination
that's unbelievably great unbelievably
great and then she's asked about
Elizabeth Warren or Amy Klobuchar she's
as I've talked to them she says I still
answer their questions I've talked to
you practically everybody who had run
and is still running and then she was
asked well you haven't talked to Bernie
said no I can't say I've talked to all
of them but I answered their questions I
always say to the female candidates look
you can run the best campaign but you're
gonna have to be even better than your
best campaign to overcome some of the
unfairness that will be directed at you
house a woman and hear a Hillary's
victimhood
complex is so strong here it's so strong
and it is so off-putting and I am so I
can't express to you how excited I am
it Hillary Clinton and Bernie Sanders
are finally opening up their guns on one
another
it is fantastic and I would encourage
Bernie Sanders supporters to remember
that Hillary Clinton - except from the
Iowa caucuses decided to sandbag Bernie
Sanders in this what will be a highly
publicized interview and that Bernie
Sanders was sandbagged by Elizabeth
Warren and that the DNC has tried to
sandbag Bernie over and over and over
just remember you that when it comes
time for a general election of Bernie
doesn't win the nomination Hillary says
whoever gets the nomination you've got
to deal with the structural challenges
that the Republicans and their allies
have put in the way so that means you've
got to do a voter suppression because
they'll steal votes or they'll prevent
votes from happening remember that time
that all of Hillary supporters are like
Trump won't accept election results yeah
Hillary doesn't sound like she is really
up for accepting election results she
says they're now trying to purge voters
so they can try to limit the electorate
which of course there's no evidence for
you've got to deal with the theft of
your personal information particularly
your emails okay lady you're the one who
put your private emails on a server that
was not protected that would have been
you that was a crime the fact that James
Comey did not charge it as a crime does
not mean that it was not a crime it was
indeed a crime she says I saved them if
your emails haven't been stolen yet they
will be look what the Russians just did
hacking into that Ukrainian oil company
to try to dig up something or make
something up about Joe Biden's son
hunter then you've got to worry about
the propaganda the fake news the made-up
stories now you have the additional
worry of the deep fakes and people
putting words in your mouth I've tried
to try tell all the candidates the same
thing but with women I say you're
probably not going to be treated fairly
don't let it knock you off stride and
then she talks about Elizabeth Warren
and we'll get to Hilary Clinton's words
on Elizabeth Warren because Hillary is
definitely in the Warren camp but this
is just it's astonishing and it's great
and it's so true
okay what's she saying about Bernie is
true and Bernie says about her is true
and it's all true
it's all true it's what I said about the
2016 Republican primaries all the bad
stuff they're saying about each other is
true all the good stuff they say is
probably not right the same thing is
true among these Democrats we'll get
some more of that in just one second
first let us talk about making your
company better let's say that you have a
great employee just an absolute delight
at the office let's call it McKenna but
let's say that McKenna just happens to
be like the Amelia Bedelia of the office
just unbelievably clumsy let's say that
in one
day she takes her favorite class and she
just shatters it directly in the sink
and then let's say that same day you
have a guest who's gonna come on and
tape something with you and she decides
you know what I'm just gonna spill this
entire gallon it's jug of milk right in
the lobby for no reason that you can
imagine just like we're gonna spill the
milk directly and I'm not gonna cry over
the spilled milk instead I'm just gonna
go check out zip recruiter zipper Curtis
ends your job to over 100 of the web's
leading job boards but they don't stop
there with their powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scans thousands
of resumes to find people with the right
experience and then invites them to
apply to your job as applications come
in sip recruiter analyzes each one when
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match zip recruiter
is incredibly effective so effective
that four out of five employers who post
on zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the very first
day it's incredibly important to get
hiring right as you know would you like
milk all over your Lobby or your
favorite glass in pieces in the sink
right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire that is zip recruiter comm slash
Dai ly w Y re zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire ok so Hillary
Clinton concludes this interview by
talking about how Elizabeth Warren
should fight President Trump
she says it's still very hard to fight
Trump she said thought Elizabeth did a
good job at the last debate with the
only people on the stage who have won
every one of their races our Amy and me
I thought that was clever some people
loved it some people hated it it's
really hard to ever score 100 when
you're trying to navigate gender
expectations and barriers so Hillary is
still playing the i'ma woman and that's
what's provided me my losses if only I
weren't a woman if only American society
weren't sexist lady the reason you lost
is cuz nobody likes you that is the
reason you lost Donald Trump when fewer
absolute votes in Wisconsin the Mitt
Romney did and somehow you managed to
lose the state to him nobody liked you
that had nothing to do with you being a
woman it had with you being a garbage
garbage candidate I mean it's hilarious
to watch Hillary Clinton sit there and
complain about Bernie Sanders's
popularity she is the reason for Bernie
Sanders's popularity
she's widely and correctly perceived as
absolutely corrupt as willing to say
anything to get anywhere and Bernie
Sanders on the other hand is widely
perceived as honest by communists and so
he stands outside and he just says well
she represents the establishment and
Here I am representing the USSR and at
least I am an honest trot scout
I'm
at least I'm almost I mean I was putting
and I want to remove our brands of
deodorant except for one I really like
the one with the piney smell it smells
like the interior of a car from 1987 I
like that one I'll gladly shouldn't be
banned but at least I am honest Hillary
Clinton is dishonest and we all know
that's the reason why Hillary Clinton
isn't president today but Hillary is
going to just sit outside and throw
bombs and it's spectacular spectacular
and then she goes on to talk about how
she is the tip of the spear on behalf of
women now here's the best part she's
she's asked is there any piece of you
that has considered jumping into the
race she has said and then she answers
I've had so many people are urged me to
every day and I'm grateful for people's
confidence but I did think it was right
for me to step back I'll do anything I
can to defeat the current incumbent and
to reverse a lot of his damaging
policies thankfully I still have a voice
and a following well actually you don't
have much of a following but you do have
a voice and I do love that she says
she'll do anything to stop she'll do
anything to stop Trump but I won't do
that
Reggie is not going to endorse Bernie
Sanders not now you got a wonder if she
ever will
spectacular stuff now Bernie's team I'm
sure this morning is in panic this
morning I'm sure Bernie's team is very
upset and and they're saying well what
Hillary Clinton opening up the guns
Bernie Chanel campaign against the
Democratic establishment and he will win
Iowa that is the reality Joe Biden is
the Democratic establishment Hillary
Clinton is the Democratic establishment
and Hillary has now made Bernie target
number one
and she's signaled that she is behind
Elizabeth Warren so Bernie now has an
opening to paint Elizabeth Warren as
part of the establishment too if you're
Elizabeth Warren's campaign today you
can't be supremely happy that Hillary
Clinton is opening up her guns I'm
Bernie Sanders because the fact is that
everybody who supported Hillary didn't
support Bernie anyway right we already
had this race so this fragments the race
even more and it definitely gets people
very enthusiastic in the Bernie Sanders
camp for supporting Bernie Sanders so
this is when the primaries begin in
earnest okay this is when Bernie needs
to come out swinging
will he I have a feeling Bernie thus far
has been unwilling to come out swinging
thus far Bernie has been very reticent
he wouldn't do it against the Lizabeth
Warren he didn't really do it against
Hillary right I don't care about clicked
on bales if he had cared about
damn emails he could have been the
nominee against Donald Trump in 2016
well now Bernie's got a second bite at
the Apple and he should come out
swinging at the Democratic establishment
they'll hate it but what he doesn't
understand it's weird for a guy who's
anti who's who's anti party who runs
from outside the party but the fact is
that if he understood what a OC
understands which is that a lot of
Democrats inside the Democratic Party
aren't happy with the Democratic Party
he'd be running directly against Warren
directly against Biden directly against
Hillary Clinton and Hillary is such a
perfect target right now because she
lost Trump you can say she lost the
Trump what does she know about done deal
with us what does she know and here she
is attacking me two weeks before the
primaries because she's very upset that
she was not able to beat Donald Trump
and now I'm the bad guy and she won't
even support me you should support me
make me the nominee and this is this is
Bernie's time to shine but in order for
him to get that he has to be just as
aggressive as one of his surrogates the
venerable intellectually brilliant
Alexandre Ocasio Cortez now a second
we're gonna get you a OC because a OC
did a big interview with Donaghy C codes
and other intellectual luminary from the
left I guess that in just one second
first let us talk about your sleep
quality so these days I'm not getting a
lot of sleep when I do need sleep the
place I go is helix I go to my helix
sleep mattress and I lie upon it and it
is the only thing that has allowed me to
grab five moments of respite from a
chaotic life go to helix sleep come why
well because they will personalize a
mattress just for you helix sleep has a
quiz it takes just two minutes to
complete and matches your body type and
sleep preferences so the perfect
mattress for you whether you're a side
sleeper or a hot sleeper whether you
like a plush or from bed with helix
there's no more confusion there is no
more compromising helix sleep is rated
the number one mattress by GQ and Wired
magazine just go to helix sleep comm
slash men take their two-minute sleep
quiz they will match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they've got a 10 year
warranty and get to try it out for 100
nights at risk-free they'll even pick it
up for you if you don't love it but
indeed you will because it's made for
you why wouldn't you love it helix is
offering up to $200 off all mattress
orders for our listeners which is a
fantastic deal get up to 200 bucks off
at helix sleep comm slash Ben that is
helix sleep comm slash Ben H e Li X
sleep comm slash Mangano mattress made
for you you're in unique individual you
need unique mattress helix sleep calm
/ban so as they say this is where Bernie
should take a lesson from AOC because
when it comes to the caucuses
particularly Iowa one comes the Iowa
caucuses it's all about enthusiasm it's
how many people can you drive out in the
middle of the winter to vote for you and
Bernie has a lot going for him on the
score he is the most honest member of
the Democratic Party and he says the
quiet part out loud and now he can
openly campaign against an establishment
Democratic Party that is mobilizing
behind Elizabeth Warren and Joe Biden
that's what Hillary Clinton just did he
can say listen Hillary had her shot she
lost the DNC denied me my shot last time
stopped them from denying me my shot
this time hey and he should be campaign
he's honestly Bernie's intellectual
leadership which is an oxymoron if ever
I heard it Bernie's intellectual right
there Bernie's program has become the
mainstream of the Democratic Party the
New York Times recognized this yesterday
in their idiotic editorial endorsing Amy
Klobuchar and Elizabeth Warren saying
that all of his programmatic ideas have
now been implemented as part of the
Democratic party platform so what Bernie
needs to do is he needs to run from the
incise is listen they're stealing all of
my good ideas and then they don't
implement any of them because they're a
bunch of partisan and political hacks
but if they truly was standing up for
the people then they would stand up for
my plans and they would just have given
me the nomination and give me the
nomination now ALC is basically saying
this so a OSI did an interview with
Donaghy C codes yesterday and she just
launched into the Democratic Party and
again I am here for it here is a OSI
talking at MLK now 2020
explaining that the Democratic Party is
not even a left-wing party anymore now
you have to be patently insane to
believe this but she is patently in
saying if she does believe this so does
Bernie and so does a huge swath of the
Democratic Party which is why you had an
insurgency against Nancy Pelosi who is
now considered a moderate in the
Democratic caucus here is the
intellectually intellectually
stimulating aoc have a Left Party in the
United States the Democratic Party is
not a Left Party the Democratic
is a center or Center conservative party
we do not advocate for we do not we
can't even get a floor vote on Medicare
for all
not even a floor vote that gets go to
down we can't even get a vote on it so
this is not a left party there are left
members inside the Democratic Party okay
so this is the campaign
honestly that burning should be running
she's running an insurgent campaign
inside the Democratic Party what's weird
is that thus far he's been running a
campaign about the Republican Party's
evils from inside a Democratic Party the
only reason why Bernie Sanders is even a
top candidate inside the Democratic
Party is because of deep and abiding
lack of interest in the Democratic Party
by a huge swath of the Democratic Party
voting base Bernie says all the stuff
that aoc says but she is even more on
she's like even more honest version of
Bernie just says all the quiet parts out
loud and honestly I'm all for it because
let's have a clear choice let's have a
clear choice so in a second I want to
get two more alc okay so AOC does this
interview at MLK Day 2020 with Donaghy C
codes and ALC just spills out what the
radical the radical left agenda is
inside the Democratic Party ins
basically Bernie Sanders is agenda this
is the battle inside the Democratic
Party but now what's amazing about this
is that it really isn't a battle inside
the Democratic Party about ends it's
only a battle about means so you got Joe
Biden and Amy Klobuchar and even
Elizabeth Warren who are suggesting a
more incrementalist approach to these
sort of insanity that AOC is
promulgating here and that Bernie
Sanders has promulgated for years and a
OC and Bernie Sanders are mad about it
and honestly that's Bernie's campaign
right this is relevant cuz AOC is a
Bernie surrogate and she is drawing huge
crowds on the campaign trail with Bernie
because she is promising revolution not
evolution she's saying all the quiet
parts out loud and every Republican in
Trump's campaign should be recording all
of these things and making attack ads
saying that this is the Democratic Party
because it is the Democratic Party but
Bernie should be saying this stuff
inside the Democratic primaries because
he's got no other shot otherwise he's
got his one shot this is his last shot
he's 80 years old he's not gonna run
again when he's 84 years old there are
only so many years you are given on this
earth he's been a useless communist for
his entire life this is the last gap
so he may as well just be mirroring what
AOC says so AOC yesterday talked about
the free markets and it is amazing I
mean this is what so many Democrats
believe about free markets she suggests
that if you are a business person if
you're an entrepreneur if you're a
capitalist then you don't get to make a
profit off of the products in which you
have invested in risks you didn't
actually make those widgets here's AOC
trying to explain economics which is
sort of like watching a badger try to
explain calculus on a couch while
thousands of people were played
modern-day slave wages and in some cases
real slaves
real modern-day slavery all of these
people who are literally dying because
they can't afford to live and so no one
ever makes a billion dollars hmm you
take a billion dollars no one makes a
billion dollars you take a billion
dollars this is the Bernie Sanders due
by the way this is Elizabeth Warren's
view - and it's full scale insanity it's
full scale insanity it's the basic labor
theory of value this idea that the
people who generate the value in a
product are not the consumers who decide
what a valid what a product is worth
it's the quote unquote laborers who put
their labor into the product and so if
you are a capitalist and you invest in
all the capital you bought all of the
equipment you bought you built the
factory you hired all the workers you
took all the risk if this thing goes
bankrupt you are the one who is going to
lose all the money she's saying you
didn't build anything you're not the
person who put any of this together now
none of this makes any sense
particularly in a modern day economy
there's a very famous essay I the the
author escapes me called I pencil all
about the making of a pencil and the
basic premise of the essay is that there
is not one person who makes a pencil
right you don't have a pencil craftsman
instead you have the person who deals
with the graphite and then you have the
person who deals with the wood and then
you have the person it's Leonard Reed
and then the person who deals with the
paint and then you have the person who
creates the eraser and all of these
things have their own supply chains and
all those supply chains involve hundreds
if not thousands of people to generate
all of these generate really one pencil
and the cost of that pencil to the
consumer is then like 25 cents
according to AOC the cost of the pencil
presumably should be
dollars because you've had thousands of
workers involved in the making of this
one pencil and they all invested their
labor and it wasn't the capitalists who
did anything except it was the
entrepreneur who created the entire
supply chain that created the pencil in
the first place it requires the labor of
thousands of people but it requires the
coordination of all of that labor and
the risk investment of somebody at the
top whose quote-unquote sitting on the
couch Elsie's never run a business
doesn't know the first damn thing about
business if you asked her to make a
pencil
she'd have no idea how to do it if you
asked her to run a business she'd have
no idea how to do it but she thinks that
she knows better than you how people
ought to be paid which of course is
absolute nonsense and insanity but this
is cheered by the Democratic left this
is cheered by the Bernie Sanders
contingent this is Bernie Sanders's
agenda aoc does it without the mask and
you know what honestly I think the chill
be more popular inside the Democratic
Party for doing it without the mask I
think so will Bernie Sanders and then
AOC goes on to suggest that the
government is us and what she's talking
about here is the complete overthrow of
the American philosophy of individual
rights individual rights pre-existing
governments is the basic idea of the
Declaration of Independence the idea was
that we create a government in order to
protect those individual rights and if
the government were to invade those
individual rights it loses its reason
for being and is the basic premise of
the Declaration of Independence and the
American Revolution but according to AOC
and Bernie Sanders and Barack Obama and
the entire Democratic Party she just
says the quiet part out loud the
government is us we have nothing to fear
from the government the collective the
collective in the end the collective is
us so what do we have to fear from a
collective invading individual rights
after all you don't have any individual
value you're just part of that
collective in a democracy the government
is us but can we just remember that that
[Applause]
when when we fight for full
enfranchisement when we don't deny the
vote when we don't have subjects when we
fight for a democracy for the people and
by the people the government is the
public and the public decides what is
good for itself
okay I'm deeply amused itani he c-code
sitting there nodding through this went
on he see Coates has written extensively
and in in quite passionate fashion about
the evils of Jim Crow which indeed were
evil and were also majority passed laws
in the South that cracked down on
minorities was the government us there
too was the government us or did it turn
out that majorities sometimes invade the
rights of minority and the individual is
the ultimate minority AAS he goes even
further just says it right out she says
that we want your power you didn't
generate any of the power lady you
didn't do anything
you won like a few thousand votes in an
extraordinarily blue district of
Brooklyn I mean like of the Bronx wait
what the hell is wrong with you
you didn't generate she has not
generated a single thing that has done
anybody any good for her entire life
except she mixed a few drinks that is
the only thing of value she has
generated in her entire short life if
she has not created a job she's not run
a business she's not create a product or
service than anybody wants to buy but
she wants the power of people who have
done all of that because after all those
people didn't create anything the only
people created anything are the workers
weird because for literally millions of
years at least hundreds of thousands of
years there have been workers there have
been people who labored but prosperity
only began when people started investing
in the labor of others and engaging in
free trade and commerce as I mentioned
yesterday the global GDP multiplied
between 1800 and 2015 by fifteen
thousand seven hundred percent and she's
sitting here explaining that she wants
the power what qualifies this dolt to
run anything now that's my perspective
but inside the Democratic Party this
just bleep is popular to be ethical if
you're a billionaire today the thing
that you need to do is give up control
and power so I don't want your money as
much as we want your power the people
not
the people not the people really so if
the people elect a Republican then she's
okay with it because the people did
right I mean no no it turns out it's her
and by the way we don't want your money
we want your power is such a lie she
wants your money and your power and by
the way the power that Jeff bestows has
is relegated to the fact that he hires
hundreds of thousands of human beings
and allows other hundreds of thousands
of human beings to receive and ship
product she wants the power how about
you create a thing and then we can talk
about what kind of power that you've
created right how about you do like the
the leech attitude here the I'm gonna
suck away everything that you've done
because I know better than you based on
my crap econ degree from Boston
University the the utter gall of it is
astonishing AOC also has some words
about Jeff B so specifically she says
the Jeff Bezos if you really cared about
two people he would turn his company
into a worker collective alternatively
if she really believes that workers
deserve the full fruits of their labors
you know what workers can do they can
found companies they can create an LLC
anytime they want they can invest their
own time and labor in fact there are
such companies there are companies that
do that they're fully capitalistic but
instead a OC says that be Tso's who
created Amazon right from a used book
company into one of the great companies
on planet Earth
she says that B's Oh should turn his
company into a worker collective this
coming from the lady who just drove
twenty thousand jobs at her own district
first of all change your business model
mmm numbers learn if Jeff Bezos you
don't have to be Emma's if Jeff Bezos
wants to be a good person he turned
Amazon to a walker worker cooperative
not what do I do with all of this money
that I have created with this unjust
system and if usually if you're a
billionaire that means that you control
a massive system okay if you are a
billionaire what that means that you
have engaged in a billion voluntary
transactions in a free country but again
this is very popular inside the
Democratic Party Bernie Sanders by the
way of course feels exactly the same way
about all of this yesterday he tweeted
out that we needed national rent control
which is presumably the worst economic
idea in human history national rent
control basically suggests that you're
going to dictate to everybody what they
are allowed to charge for rent which
means that it will become not profitable
to create new developments which means
housing shortages which means that the
government will have to get involved and
then will have to build public housing
and this is work fantastic in places
like pruitt-igoe in st. Louis a massive
disgusting horrific ugly government
housing area that was ripped down
because it turned into a trash heap
thanks to people who live there and to
local and to local law enforcement and
and local politicians and national
politicians in the nationalization of
all of this stuff is the ultimate agenda
listen all I'm saying here is the Bernie
should run on it just do it man just do
it Hillary's coming after you Biden's
coming after you even Warren's coming
after you just go full out go for a lot
because Tucker Carlson sadly is right
because Tucker kind of agrees with
Bernie when it comes to ikana when it
comes to economics I mean I've talked to
Tucker on my show about it here is
Tucker explaining that Bernie Sanders
will win from voters one of my favorite
things about Tucker's take on economics
in this sort of context is he will very
often say socialism is really bad but
also Republicans should figure out a way
to relieve the student loan crisis okay
you're gonna have to define why you
think socialism is bad if you actually
think the government should be relieving
the student loan crisis where people
voluntarily took on debt and then
refused to pay back the debt Bernie
Sanders may get the Democratic
nomination and if he does every
Republican in Washington will spend the
next ten months
reminding you that socialism does not
work and never has worked and they'll be
right obviously but if Sanders pledges
to forgive student loans he will still
win many thousands of voters who went
for Donald Trump last time why because
debt is crushing an entire generation of
Americans Republicans need to make a
plan to make it better or they will be
left behind
okay so Republicans need to make big
government plans this is why I say
burnish you just go for it
you should just go for it you should
just own it okay now let's talk about
impeachment so we'll get to that in just
one second but first if you know
anything about me you've most likely
heard about my talk about pro-life
causes I talk about private causes all
the time you also remember last year i
stream my podcast live from the March
for Life in DC I gave a speech to
hundreds of thousands of people marching
for the cause well you may not be aware
of is that we got enormous blowback from
our political adversaries there were
astroturfed targeted campaigns against
some of our advertisers several of our
advertisers actually pulled the ads out
of the show that was not the first time
it nor will likely be the last time that
we're attacked in an attempt to shut
down pro-life voices we're also not the
only targets live action is one of the
biggest voices in the pro-life movement
they are fantastic the run by Lila Rose
a good friend of mine I donate money to
live action they really are terrific
they continue to do some of the most
important work in the pro-life space
from raising awareness and education on
the abortion issue to undercover videos
that expose Planned Parenthood and other
abortion clinics or horrific human
rights abuses they've been banned from
advertising on Twitter for their calls
to defund Planned Parenthood they've
been targeted by a bevy of social media
companies and so right now we are doing
something special here at Daily wire and
that is if you subscribe right now if
you become a daily wire member and you
help us out you help protect us from the
left trying to cancel the pro-life
message then we will also give a portion
of those proceeds to live action from
now until January 31st so from now until
January 31st a portion of any daily
wire.com membership will be donated to
live action with promo code live action
you support awareness and education
around the world on this issue so you
can feel really good while you are
getting the benefit of a daily where
membership that you are also doing
something good for the world and for the
pro-life movement so go check that out
right now it's a pretty awesome deal
Billy you should make you feel good
about yourself go check it out right now
we are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
all righty so the the Mitch McConnell
led Senate is now planning to give house
impeachment managers and president
Donald Trump's legal team each
twenty-four hours divided over two days
for their opening arguments in the
Senate impeachment trial and Democrats
are fighting mad about all of this now
the impeachment trial of President
Clinton did involve each side getting 24
hours but those 24 hours or split over a
four-day period so that drag this thing
out is like six hours per day for four
days this time it's gonna be 12 hours
per day for two days for each side which
means late-night sessions oh no we're
gonna make our Senators work it's so
funny to hear senators complain about
this on the Democratic side I thought
this was the most urgent thing that ever
happened and if we don't impeach Trump
right now and he's gonna steal the
election but you do it you guys don't
want to stay up to 1:00 in the morning I
mean normally you're up to one of the
morning banging hookers anyway so what
do you care and seriously you're just
gonna have to be on the floor to the
Senate listening to people jabber I
understand it's a letdown from the heavy
drinking that you normally do in your
off hours but you know presumably you
could stick around for a couple extra
hours and and listen to something to
some of us Democrats opposed McConnell's
scheduled House Democratic aide said
Monday was an effort to conceal the
president's misconduct in the dark of
night oh really I'm sure that the media
will not the media have obviously been
very skimpy in their coverage of
President Trump I'm sure that if the
cameras have to be rolling at 11:00 p.m.
then the media won't be able to cover it
in any way I'm sure they're just gonna
all go to sleep down lemon and Chris
Cuomo are just gonna say you know what
it's 11 p.m. I'm not gonna offer the
night not gonna cover this stuff
according to Senate Minority Leader
Chuck Schumer he said it's clear Senator
McConnell is hell bent hell bent on
making it much more difficult to get
witnesses and documents and intent on
rushing the trial through it's hilarious
to watch the house say we need to rush
it through we need to rush it rush it
now it's important do it now we can't
wait for witnesses do it now now now in
McConnell's like okay let's also rush it
through I'll rush it through now we'll
get to a vote it'll cuz it weighs whoa
whoa there Mitch hold your horses now we
gots to call the witnesses and we gotta
do it for months at a time if we can
carry this thing all the way through til
like 2029 we would make that happen
Chuck Schumer said on something as
important as impeachment Senator
McConnell's resolution is nothing short
of a national disgrace
ah there is Chuck Schumer saying this is
so tough it's so terrible
no no it's awful is now certain that
leader McConnell is going along with
president Trump's cover-up hook line and
sinker when you look at his resolution
it's no wonder he delayed it till the
last minute he didn't want people to
study it or know about it after reading
McConnell's resolution it's clear
McConnell is hell-bent on making it much
more difficult to get witnesses and
documents and intent on rushing the
trial through again they rushed the
entire thing through the house they
still have the ability and senator Tim
Scott pointed out yesterday of South
Carolina they still have the ability any
time they want to call new witnesses in
the house they can well Adam Schiff is
appearing on CNN every night he could be
figuring out how to call john bolton he
could be working it through the legal
system he's not here's Tim Scott saying
I don't understand we're supposed to
call witnesses that the house refuses to
call and then we're bad if we don't do
what they would they wouldn't do they do
have the opportunity to have votes I
look forward to voting no on any witness
that was not a witness during the house
it is not our responsibility as senators
to help improve or expand the case the
way that we understand the process the
house sends over a completed case and we
make a decision based on that completed
case if the house doesn't like the case
is sent over then they need to do
something in the house to change that
case okay well they're not going to do
anything in the house obviously which is
why they are militating against Mitch
McConnell's rules and complaining about
them by the way the notion that they're
not gonna call witnesses again they
still have to take a vote on whether to
call witnesses and there's nothing
different about that that in the Clinton
impeachment in 1999 when it was unclear
how many witnesses were going to be
called once the thing actually hit the
Senate according to CNN the organizing
resolution is the opening salvo in
what's shaping up to be a bitterly
contested impeachment trial after the
House passed two articles of impeachment
last month
charging Trump with abuse of power and
obstruction of Congress and just gonna
point out the media back in 1999 thought
that witnesses were a sham at the Senate
shouldn't call in the witnesses
the same members of the media who today
are like we need new witnesses where
it's a cover-up Oh issue has been a sham
it shouldn't have gotten this far the
house acted improperly and passing it on
to the Senate
why is your party dragging this thing
out why is this happening why go through
all this this business about witnesses
do we really need more witnesses it's
gonna add once to this thing we should
stop this this bogus inflated case well
these people just get down to business
and leave this impeachment thing alone
it's going to be an enormous distraction
and those were reporters okay then one
of those reporters asking Bob Dole Bob
Dole asking Bob Dole about this yes it's
so much journalism being even back then
so much journalism a McConnell's
organizing resolution puts off the
question of witnesses until after the
two sides present their opening
arguments and there are sixteen hours of
questions for senators which they will
ask through Supreme Court Chief Justice
John Roberts who's presiding over the
trial who has the he has the worst
schedule in Washington he has to go here
Supreme Court cases in the morning and
then he asked to rush on over to the
Senate in the afternoon and preside over
this dumb impeachment at that point the
resolution includes a proposal in which
the Senate would vote on a motion to on
whether it shall be in order to consider
and debate under the impeachment rules
any motions who subpoena witnesses or
documents should enough Republicans vote
with Democrats to call witnesses says
CNN the White House and Republican
allies will be ready a senior
administration official and a person
familiar confirmed the White House has
been involved in discussion with GOP
allies over the last several days to
make sure they're ready in the event
that Democrats have get enough votes to
allow witnesses to be called to testify
the sources say part of those
discussions involve the implications
such as executive privilege concerns if
John Bolton Mick Mulvaney Office of
Management and Budget official Mike
Duffy and White House aide Robb Blair
are forced to publicly testify there are
a series of contingencies were prepared
said a senior administration well you
would imagine they would be right I mean
like this is a very long telegraph punch
right here meanwhile president from the
legal team has released a 110 page brief
rebutting a lot of the charges put forth
by Democrats in their own impeachment
brief Byron York has good synopsis of
all of this over at Washington Examiner
he says on Monday the White House
released a 110 page defense memorandum
signed by White House Counsel Pat's
abalone and from lawyer Jay Sekulow in
it the two lawyers addressed the
substance of the Democratic charges
against the president Trump's phone call
with the Ukrainian president
on July 15 2015 19 the decision to
withhold and later deliver security
assistance to Ukraine the legitimacy of
trumps concerns about Ukrainian
activities in the 2016 election and the
case of hunter Biden and more in other
words all the things the president's
adversary said he could not address all
those things are addressed in the simple
oniy Sekulow memo lawyers also
criticized the process of impeachment on
the substance of the abuse of power
article against the president Cipollone
ian Sekulow presents a detailed analysis
of the July 25th call and the events
surrounding it the rough transcript of
the call released by the White House on
September 20 25 20 19 quote shows the
president did nothing wrong they write
trump's discussion of burden sharing has
been a consistent theme of his
presidency as far as the president's
discussion of the 2016 election was
concerned uncovering foreign
interference in US elections is always a
legitimate goal whatever the source of
that interference and whether or not it
fits with Democrats preferred narrative
there were in fact legitimate concerns
about Ukrainian efforts to influence the
2016 election it was also legitimate to
bring up the issue of hunter Biden and
Murray's m'a argue Trump's lawyers quote
public reports indicate that then Vice
President Biden threatened to
withholding US loan guarantees to secure
the dismissal of the Ukrainian
prosecutor even though Biden was at the
time operating under what appeared to be
at the very least a serious conflict of
interest then there was the issue of the
temporarily withheld assistance there
was no discussion of the pause security
assistance on that July 25th phone calls
had said baloney and seculow the
Ukrainians have said there was no
pressure on them they did not know that
security assistance had been paused at
the time of the call House Democrats
charges for lead further disproved but a
straightforward fact had not a single
witness with actual knowledge ever
testified that the president suggested
any connection between announcing
investigations and security assistance
now so I think that Trump did Everett
was that a perfect phone call no wasn't
a perfect phone call it gave the
appearance of impropriety do I think the
Trump was likely conditioning Ukrainian
eight like the problem with Trump's case
is that he doesn't explain why he was
conditioning Ukrainian eight he just
sort of was out there so I think that it
had something to do with the Ukrainian
government investigating Purisima and
Joe Biden I do too I think it had to a
20/20 as opposed to 2016 no I don't and
that is where you move from the
impeachable to the non impeachable so
Trump does have responses to all of this
and the fact is that this thing is going
to be over within a week by the new
schedule there will be 24 hours each
side gets 24 hours so that the whole
thing should take I believe four days
and then you get witnesses even if you
have a few witnesses you're gonna get
like maybe five witnesses if you get any
witnesses and those witnesses may take
another week okay well that means that
today's date is January 21st so by early
February there's a good shot that by the
time from speaks in the State of the
Union he's already been acquitted in the
Senate that is a very solid shot okay
time for a quick thing that I like and
then we will get you some things that I
hate so things that I like the other day
I recommended the new Terminator movie
Terminator at dark fate so now it's time
to recommend the best Terminator movie
the only truly great Terminator movie
that of course is terminator 2 now I
know there are a lot of terminator 1
fans too many ones fine yes it's good
but it really serves only as the
predicate for Terminator 2 one of the
best action films in the history of
movies great Arnold it's it's clever
it's the action scenes are well staged
the special effects pretty much hold up
it's pretty spectacular here's a little
bit of the trailer if you've never seen
Terminator 2 not for the case great
movie he's a terminator like you right
not like me g1000 advanced prototype
[Music]
come with me if you want to live we
don't have much time
okay the movies great but every other
line is a quotable line it's just
fantastic so if you're in the mood for a
good action flick and you've never seen
Terminator 2 you're missing out
Terminator 2 is great okay time for some
things that that I hate okay so over the
last 24 hours there was this massive
rally in Virginia about 22,000 people
showed up by crowd estimates bigger than
the women's March in Washington DC this
big crowd shows up at the Virginia
capital to protest a bunch of gun
measures gun control measures pushed
forward by Ralph Northam now there is
not widespread support in the state of
Virginia for severe gun control there
just isn't
okay there's at best support for carving
around the edges of gun rights but
they're the kind of right to the heart
of it restricting ownership of assault
weapons like that just is not widespread
support for that in a gun heavy state
like Virginia because there was this
pro-gun rally at the Virginia Capitol
the media decided that they were going
to treat this thing as though it was an
incipient terror attack and this was
exacerbated by the fact that there were
some actual white supremacists who said
that they wanted to cut they were
arrested they wanted to come to the
actual events and then start shooting
they're shooting whom you know not clear
exactly whether they're gonna shoot the
constituents shoot a cops they wanted to
start trouble because this is what white
supremacists do because they're the
worst people on planet earth they're
just awful evil pieces of human debris
the media decided instead to play it as
though this rally was filled with white
supremacist the headline from The
Huffington Post at yesterday suggested
that thousands is a close close
paraphrase maybe direct quote thousands
of pro-gun activists and far-right
extremists rally in Richmond I love how
they just sort of conflate pro-gun
activists and far-right extremists no
breakdown as to what exactly that looks
like how many far-right extremists were
there how many pro-gun activists
absolutely unclear the media yesterday
were just itching for something bad to
happen like they would have loved
nothing better than four shots to be
fired because then they could suggest
that all gun owners are actually crazed
Kooks who wants to start violence who
want to disobey the law and that is why
we have to seize their guns from them
right I mean it's why the favorite
argument of the left is finding crazy
people with guns and they never want to
talk about law-abiding citizens with
guns protecting themselves and their
families and their rights instead they
want to portray gun owners as
legitimately nuts and so when they get
22,000 people
in one place all it takes is one shot
fired for the media to get what they
want and the media were just ruling for
yesterday here's a little bit of montage
various members of the media spreading
fear as to what was going to happen to
Virginia Capitol it turned out to be a
perfectly nice rally everybody showed up
everybody left nobody got hurt there
weren't even any that people were
cleaning up their trash in other words
it was like a tea party rally I'm old
enough for a member of the tea party in
2010 2009-2010 and I'm old enough to
remember when the media portrayed tea
parties as incipient terror hot beds
when it was a bunch of Americans
gathering together to say the Pledge of
Allegiance and talk about founding
principles and then clean up their
garbage here's the media doing the same
thing at this pro-gun rally in Virginia
yesterday hate groups supposedly some
white nationalist white nationalist
white nationalist groups white
supremacist white supremacist white
supremacist white extremist this entire
rally stands in opposition to the
meaning of this day Virginia on the edge
how concerned are you that there might
be some people in this crowd that may
want to get violent certainly a lot of
concern here raising fears of a
dangerous confrontation it could be
violence and there is real concern there
about what the intention is behind this
a lot of concern about the potential for
violence and this was the constant
chatter yesterday and governor Ralph
Northam of course exacerbated that by
declaring the state of emergency as
though this is gonna be another
Charlottesville there was a rather large
difference okay rather a large
difference between Charlottesville and
the rally yesterday in Richmond the
rally in Charlottesville was
legitimately organized by white
supremacists and marketed as a white
supremacist rally their poster showed
Confederate soldiers marching and Nazi
like War Eagles on the poster Richard
Spencer was the keynote speaker hey this
was a normal pro-gun rally end of story
and by the way it is legal to carry guns
in the state of Virginia in the way that
people were carrying guns yesterday if
they had not been acting legally they
would have been arrested Ralph Northam
however tweeted out we are all thankful
that today passed without incident well
it was really only you suggesting that
there was going to be an incident
imagine if there been a left-wing rally
and a right-wing governor had said we're
all grateful that today passed without
incident the team's successfully
de-escalated what could have been a
volatile situation
de-escalated where was the de-escalation
where was the escalation that required
the de-escalation like I'm confused I
didn't see any video if people start and
get violent and believe me the media
would been all over it and then the cops
coming in and escalating the situation
in fact
the only people who didn't show up
yesterday were the folks from antiva
we're the ones who are going around the
country precipitating conflict so Ralph
Northam pushing the idea that we
narrowly avoided bloodshed in Richmond
yesterday is perfectly insane he has no
evidence that bloodshed was in the
offing from the people who were there
and the people who were gonna show up
into bloodshed thank God law enforcement
did its job it's unbelievable Chris
Hayes though suggests that carrying guns
is in and of itself an implicit threat
of violence here's Chris Hayes on MSNBC
grabbing those Rachel Maddow glass and
going for it
peaceable assembly the petitioner
government is protected in the First
Amendment even if you know you don't
agree with people I just like I guess I
struggle with like just the implied
message of armed folks and sometimes the
explicit message is that like we will
use these if you try to enact your laws
I mean I think there's no question when
you look at those images and watch the
TV screens of mostly white men marching
armed to the hilt the level of
intimidation and fear that that can
stalk is terrifying intimidation and
fear I mean like none of these people
were there I know they feel afraid when
they see in a well while biting American
citizen with a gun and I know it scares
the bejesus out of them when you suggest
them that perhaps if the government
violates fundamental rights under the
Constitution of the United States that
people will disobey that I know this
scares them but that happens to be a
pretty rich tradition in American
history and nobody was using guns
yesterday nobody was threatening
politicians yesterday nobody was doing
anything illegal yesterday and and
making clear to the politicians that if
you try to tyrannize the American
population that you are exacerbating
conflict that's not a terrible thing and
by the way you don't have to carry a gun
to do it I say it on the show all the
time I say it on the show all the time
hey the carrying of the guns is to
demonstrate that you do have the right
to carry guns and that's not a right to
people are gonna go along with being
taken away Sheriff Richard Vaughan is a
law enforcement officer in Virginia he
says listen we're not going to enforce
unconstitutional laws by the way you
know a lot of people getting very upset
about this we're not going to enforce
unconstitutional laws says the sheriff
what about rule of law well one of the
aspects of rule of law under the
Constitution is that when you take an
oath to the Constitution you're supposed
to obey the Constitution not people who
violate the Constitution in the name of
the Constitution so here Sheriff Richard
Vaughan explaining
that he is not going to be mobilized in
favor of disarming law-abiding American
citizens just because a bunch of
Democratic politicians don't like guns
if the bills go through is proposed they
will not be enforced they're
unconstitutional we swore to uphold the
Constitution the United States and the
Constitution of Virginia okay and
everybody is getting very mad at this
guy how dare they it's funny they're
they're fine with local law enforcement
saying we won't we won't work with the
feds to crack down on illegal
immigration which is an actual crime but
when a sheriff says listen I'm not gonna
go door-to-door and try to disarm
law-abiding Americans just because Ralph
Northam governor kuehnemund wants me to
then obviously very very bad very very
bad indeed one protester made very clear
he says listen here's what's happening
here the media there's a black protester
wearing a make America great again hat
which just boggles the little minds in
the media because obviously if you're
black you're not allowed to support
Trump the protester says northern is
trying to equate this with
Charlottesville and that of course is
true the media have a very bad habit of
trying to equate everything with
Charlottesville everything everybody is
alright everybody is a wild right-wing
extremist who wants bloodshed and by the
way if you're if you're a tyrants who
wants to remove fundamental American
rights then you're a moderate if you're
a OC
then you're just a peaceful moderate who
is seeking to make the country better
even while you are calling for the
nationalization of nearly every industry
and the destruction of all American
rights in the name of the government
because of course the government is us
but if you're a law-abiding American
citizen who takes your gun to a pro-gun
rally then of course you're terrorists
here is the here is this this black
protester talking about this they want
to like it mr. Charlottesville and they
want to anticipate crime and violence
but these are peaceful people who come
come around with their weapons and
they're showing up here to send one
message and that is a message of unity
you know this this this government
thinks this is just white people just
just just a few black people there are
there are people here who united from
the hills from the mountain
from the valleys and the message is one
message and that is that we want the
Second Amendment to remain intact that
tape is courtesy of Breitbart news by
the way it's very weird to watch members
of the media who are complaining that
these rallies are too white then
presumably ignore all the black people
who are actually at the rallies and
suggest also that black people should be
against gun ownership which is a weird
take considering that the most
victimized minority in American history
are black Americans and that many black
Americans have in fact defended
themselves with firearms from the
predations of white racists coming after
them alright we'll be back here a little
bit later today with two additional
hours of content we will see you here
later today or tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling assistant director Pavel
Whitehouse key technical producer Austin
Stephens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam sy events audio
is mixed by Mike rapport Amina hair and
makeup is by Anika Geneva the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 25 yesterday
white supremacist Hitler loving
neo-nazis wearing make America great
again hats and toting fully
semi-automatic double-barreled a r-47
assault rifles descended on the Virginia
State House to take over the government
and establish a Prussian ethno state in
the fevered imagination of the
mainstream media in reality law-abiding
gun owners of all colors and backgrounds
showed up on Lobby day to defend their
constitutionally protected civil rights
and there was no violence whatsoever and
they cleaned up after themselves when
they left we will examine of Virginia
gun owners shutdown the leftist
narrative on the Second Amendment then
AOC has the dumbest conversation I've
ever heard we get ready for impeachment
and we get even more ready for the March
for Life check it out on the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]